a gift for the movie can take your mind
off the anxieties of the world and put
you in the shoes of people with way
bigger problems than you whether the
threats they're facing a deadly
supernatural or imaginary these trailers
on Netflix will keep you busy for a
while you're talking to me you're
talking to me everyone knows a line and
it's sauce has 1976's taxi driver a film
that critics have spent decades hailing
as one of the best films of all time
Travis Bickle can't sleep and when he
can't sleep he drives his cab he has no
friends and he can't connect with women
the increasingly paranoid Bickle's he's
nothing but hostility around him and his
reaction is to arm himself for a one-man
war against what he sees as a crumbling
society around him taxi driver is a
powerful and absolutely essential film
directed by Martin Scorsese featuring
early work by acclaimed actors like
Harvey Keitel Jodie Foster
Cybill Shepherd and of course Robert De
Niro if you haven't seen it see it if
you've already seen it odds are you
wouldn't mind seeing it again for most
of 2016 the invitation you're not sure
what's real and what the characters are
imagining the film stars Logan Marshall
Greene as well a man still traumatized
by the death of his son he and his wife
Eden divorce after their son's death
well-well still accepts her invitation
to a dinner party hosted by Eden and a
new husband David
well doesn't know what to make of his
ex-wife's weird behavior or the other
eccentric guests but he's sure there's
more going on than just a party the rest
of the film and falls entirely at the
dinner party with a guest acting
stranger and stranger old friends make
shocking confessions and wells paranoia
continues to mount mentioning many more
details would give far too much away but
we can say the invitation is a
fascinating slow burn that played with
our social boundaries seeing how far the
hero is willing to go along with the
facade before finally cutting through
the party's expectations to find out
what's really going on I don't want to
spoil anyone's fun it's just isn't my
thing
just just let her go David I can't you
just leave no but this has nothing to do
with Seth Rogen and James Franco [ __ ]
North Korea the interview we're talking
about is a 1998 Australia made thriller
starring Hugo Weaving as the
impoverished Eddie Rudd Lee Fleming
who's tracked into a police
interrogation room for reasons unknown
at first the police don't give Fleming
any idea why he's there but it slowly
becomes clear they suspect him of being
the culprit in a series of slayings
eventually we learn that as much as the
detectives are doing their best to keep
Fleming in the dark unbeknownst to them
they're being monitored as well aside
from some flashback sequences all of the
interview takes place in the small dark
interrogation room in which Fleming and
his interrogators find themselves it
kept guessing until the end about
whether or not Fleming is as innocent as
he claims and what the film essentially
being one long and hostile conversation
the actors intense talents get the
chance to shine all on their own 1922
released in 2017 is based on the Stephen
King novella of the same name and could
easily be seen as something of a
spiritual successor to Edgar Allan Poe's
19th century classic story the tell-tale
heart
wolf doesn't want to Sallust abrasca
farm but as why far less is determined
to leave it behind and move to Omaha
early on in the movie wolf kills are
left with the help of their son Henry
and hides the body in a well after the
killing will sponsor for some
inexplicable calamities including swarms
of rats that just won't leave wealth
alone wolf begins to lose his marbles
but the question is whether it's a lets
vengeful spirit who's driving wealth
bunkers or if it's the guilt and angst
over killing her that is forcing wealth
to see what isn't there with Stephen
King as the author behind the story you
should go into it knowing that either
possibility makes sense calibre is a
simple of a smart film about two men who
keep making all the wrong decisions
their first mistake leads to their
second and so on and still they're far
beyond the point of no return focusing
on two protagonists on a hunting trip
gone wrong calibre is a movie rooted in
realism and the complexities of real
human behavior it's easy to imagine
yourself getting into a similar mess
which makes what happens all the more
gut-wrenching in the beginning of
caliber his Vaughn who seems like the
responsible one compared to his friend
Marcus but the next day it's Vaughn's
era that changes everything for both
friends setting a grisly series of
events in
it makes for an exceedingly watchable
movie that garnered great reviews
elevating a simple premise with
fantastic execution in Gerald's game a
woman named Jessie finds herself living
through a terrible what-if scenario
after a luckily allowing her husband
Gerald to handcuff her to a bed
he suddenly dies of a heart attack
forcing her into a horrifying ordeal and
leaving her trapped in a remote lake
house without food water or any way to
free herself what follows is a faithful
adaptation of the Stephen King novel
upon which the film is based Jessie is
terrorized by threats both real and
imagined and that's rarely able to tell
one from another close your eyes
there's a monster under your bed it
won't bother you fiercely director Mike
Flanagan reportedly carried around
Gerald's game for years one thing to
make a film based on the book even when
he was in high school his dedication to
the source material shines through in
his adaptation but he made an absorbing
thriller whether you've read the book or
not par thriller and part murder mystery
the most assassinated woman in the world
is a french maid film about a woman who
dies on stage every night and we don't
mean the same way a stand-up comic does
the film is set in the 1930s when stage
actress Paula Maxo earns a reputation of
the most assassinated in the world
because of the death scenes our
character enjoys every night in the
Grand Guignol theater of Paris after a
journalist visits Maxtor in a dressing
room for a story it soon becomes clear
that Max's most assassinated title is
more literal than anyone realizes at the
same time suspicion is brewing that
Max's performances are inspiring
real-life killings in Paris
it makes for a surprisingly fun and
enthralling mystery about the blurry
lines that can exist between fantasy and
reality
Coosh my ciske vera you cannot shut your
royal envoy the platform has a stronger
element of science fiction the most
trailers and conveys some powerful
social messages the movie focuses on
prisoners in a dystopian Gulick with a
particularly cruel system of feeding its
inmates a platform descends to the
facility one level at a time at the top
level the platform is filled with food
but as it drops to the lower level
the amount of food is never replenished
so while the prisoners are the uppermost
levels are all but guaranteed their
health the further you go down the more
likely you'll be left starving
as the film continues we see what
desperate and savage measures the
facility's inhabitants are willing to
take to keep what they have and get what
they don't know platform it's a kind of
film you should definitely see once
though you may never want to watch again
you'll appreciate its sharp social
commentary and it's wickedly dark humor
but it's a brutal and bleak film and not
for the faint of heart check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]